تمام
احنا مباشر نعم
والله انا مش
كاميرا يعني
كده اهو يا جماعه
لا ما فيش مشكله
تمام كده مساء الخير على حضراتكم مع بث
مباشر جديد اتمنى ان شاء الله يكون بث
مستمر ويعني مفيد جت الاسئله سريعا انا بس
قبل ما اجاوب الاسئله لان انا جت لي رساله
من صديق انا اسف الاسئله جت سريعه جدا لكن
انا جت لي رساله من صديقه كاتب اسمه عندي
اهو الاستاذ مصطفى ابو هدروس يا استاذ
مصطفى انت زعلان وبعثت لي رساله عاتب علي
ان انا لم اجب على سؤالك وانا لم ارى هذا
السؤال او لم اكن اعلم اجابته اصلا
سؤال حضرتك انت بتتكلم على جثامين الشهداء
الفلسطينيين اللي بتحتفظ بهم اسرائيل
ثلاجات لا اعلم شيء عن هذا الموضوع
كحقائق مؤكده تواصلت من مع من اثق فيه قال
لي برضو ان ليس لديه حقائق لكن معلوماته
كالتالي هناك عشرات الجثامين اللي موجوده
في ثلاجات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي او
السلطه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه وان هي
بتحتفظ بهذه الجثث وفقا لمعلوماته
لاحد سببين السبب المباشر انه بتامل بان
هذه الجثمين تبقى وسيله للضغط على جماعات
المقاومه
علشان اسرائيل تسترد اسراها اللي هم اظن
اربع جنود منهم اتنين تعتقد اسرائيل ان هم
اوريدي خلاص توفوا وفي
اشاعات اخرى او في معلومات اخرى بتقول ان
هي استخدمت بعض اعضاء المتوفين والذين تم
اغتيالهم او تصفيتهم من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
كاعطاء هذه المعلومات ليست مؤكده لكن هذا
ما توفر لي من معلومات وانت وفرت لا يدي
مزيد من المعلومات المؤكده حتى الان
سوف اخبرك به اعتذر لك واعتذر للاصدقاء
اللي بيبعتوا لي اسئله وبيقول لي انا ببعت
كل مره على الهوا ما بتردش والله مش مقصود
انا فعلا عيني ما بتعرفش السؤال الا لما
بتقع عليه على كل الاحوال اكرر يعني
تحياتي لكم ونبدا بالسؤال الاولاني
السلام عليكم عندي سؤال استاذ سيد لقد
سمعت او سمعت ان من
انا من مصلحه كل الدول المتقدمه ان تساعد
كل الدول الفقيره لكي تجبر اقتصاداتها
ويصبح سوقها اكبر وبالتالي وارداتها ما
رايك في ذلك اه هو يعني عبد الرحمن بيقول
انه ان الدول المتقدمه بتحاول مساعده
الدول الفقيره عشان تكبر ما رايك في ذلك
اه طبعا هو يعني
تخيل مثلا انه بلد زي المانيا او زي الصين
او زي الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا هل من
مصلحتها مثلا انه دوله زي السودان تنهار
تماما وبالتالي تفقد السوق السوداني كله
ولا من مصلحتها ان السوق السوداني يكون
واقف على رجليه وبالتالي لا تتهدد موارد
هذه الدول من المواد الخام اللي بتصدر
للسودان ولا يتاثر السوق السوداني او
السوق المصري او السوق الافريقي كله او
السوق الاسيوي كله سوء
مستهلك لمنتجات هذه الدول اكيد دي مصلحتها
وبالتالي من مصلحه الدول الكبيره ان هي
تحافظ على استقرار في الغالب طبعا ما لم
تكن هناك مصلحه محدده في بلد معين ان هي
تكون واقفه على رجليها لكن
في فرق ان انت تكون واقف على رجليك وان
انت تبقى بلد منافس هو عاوزك تبقى واقف
على رجليك بالقدر الذي يسمح بتدفق موادك
الخام اليه وبقدر ما يكون سوق قادر على
استيعاب وشراء المنتجات النهائيه التي
يصدرها فقط لكن اكيد مش هيكون سعيد يعني
لو انت تطورت الى الحد الذي يخليك تستغنى
عنه
ادم
ادم هنسن ترامب وفي اكثر من مناسبه قال
انه يمكنه انهاء الحرب اكيد يقصد حرب
اوكرانيا خلال 24 ساعه
هل هذه دعايه من اجل الانتخابات
ام هذا يعني انه يعني ما يقول وما تفسيرك
اذا كان فعلا يستطيع فعل ذلك اشكرك من
القلب على مجهودك وحياتك وصدقك شكرا يا
ادم بص يا ادم
اللي بيقولوا الرئيس ترامب طبعا في مبالغه
الرجل بطبيعته مبالغ وحتى مره قرات انا
مانيش يعني
فقيه يعني في الثقافات الامريكيه الداخليه
ولكن حتى سالت بعض اصدقائي الامريكان
فقالوا لي انه اهل النيويورك وهو من اهل
نيويورك بيتمتعوا بشخصيه تميل الى
المبالغه في كل تعبيراتهم ولو ركبت تصرفات
والفاظ ترامب هو رجل مبالغ
لكن ما يقصدوا انه اذا وصل للسلطه هو قادر
على وقف الحرب انا اصدقه في هذا لانه
الولايات المتحده سواء في
اداره ترامب اذا جاء للسلطه او في اداره
بيدن الحاليه قادره ان تلعب دورا كبيرا
جدا في وقف هذه الحرب لانه المسافه مش
بعيده وده اللي انا كنت بتكلم عليه وطبعا
في ناس اهم مني كتير اتكلموا عليه ان يمكن
وقف هذه الحرب لان المطالب الروسيه ليست
مستحيله وليست مستغربه ودي قصه اتكلمنا
عنها كثيرا لكن الولايات المتحده فيها
تيار
يبدو مش يبدو تبين لنا انه بيعتقد ان
مصلحه الولايات المتحده هي في الابقاء على
هذه الحرب لاطول فتره ممكنه
[موسيقى]
حقوق الانسان
والقيم الليبراليه اللي هم بيتبنوها نفس
هذا الجناح اللي هو بيدافع بشده عن حقوق
المثليين وحقوق الاقليات العرقيه والحقوق
الدينيه بعض هذه الدعاوى بتلقى قبول من
عندنا وبعضها بيختلف معادي قصه تانيه لكن
هذا الجناح يكره بوتين جدا وبيعتبره مستبد
يفضل اسقاطه وفي فريق اخر بينضاف اليه بين
الامريكان انه فرصه اتاتنا
لتصفيه الخطر اللي بيمثلوا بوتون والتوجه
القومي فتم الزرع شيطاني والنخبه اللي
معاه لانها باتت تمثل خطر على المصالح
الامريكيه بالخطاب القومي القومي يعني ايه
انه روسيا يجب ان تكون دوله عظيمه ان هي
روسيا في حاله خصام مع الغرب انه روسيا
لازم تكون دوله قويه انه وهكذا قولوا فرصه
نستنزفوا
وبيعتقدوا ان هم قادرين على ان الحرب تسير
بشكل قادر على
استنزاف الروس ولكن لن يصعد الى درجه ان
الروس يستفز يتم استفزازهم ويستخدموا
السلاح النووي فبيعتقدوا ان
اداره الصراع بالشكل ده تصب فيه مصلحتهم
خصوصا بان اجهاد روسيا خصم من القوه
الصينيه اللي بتعول على الشراكه مع الروس
في مواجهه الغرب في المواجهه المؤجله
ولكنها يعني حتميه في المستقبل
كلام ترامب بيختلف وبالتالي انا اصدقه اذا
جاء يستطيع ان يلعب دورا في تهدئه الامور
بدون خسائر للامريكان
وبدون بدون عدد كبير يعني بدون صعبه كبيره
وسيم بيقول نعم الصوت تمام شكرا
مساء الورد لماذا كانت العلاقه بين مصر
وايران منقطعه
وما هو موقف اسرائيل من المصالحه بينهما
داء عميد بيقول شوف يا صديقي دي قصه طويله
عاوزه لها حلقه لوحدها ولكن الكلام اللي
على الورق اللي هو محتاج العلاقه انقطعت
من
ازور من البدايه من عام 79
يعني تقريبا بمجرد اندلاع الثوره
الاسلاميه او ثوره الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
سنه 79
سبب القطع من ايران وتوتر العلاقه مع مصر
مجموعه من الاسباب اولا بدايه ان مصر كانت
هي البلد
ايران الذي ثار عليه الايرانيون
فهذا هذا الايرانيين الامر الثاني
استقبلوا استسادات هنا ودفن هنا وموجود
ضريحه
في مسجد شهير اللي هو مسجد الرفاعي امام
مسجد السلطان حسن وهما مزاران يستحقان
الزياره للمصريين والغير المصريين
ثم توترت العلاقه اكثر بين الايرانيين
وبين
المصريين لما انور السادات اتم اتفاقيه
السلام او صار فيها واكمل فيها لان كارت
البوادر قبل الثوره الاسلاميه يعني كان
الغضب موجود من عقده اتفاقيه السلام ثم
قامت الثوره واستقبل شيخ ايران
انه
الايرانيين بمجرد اغتيال السادات احتفوا
بذلك بشكل كبير جدا واطلقوا احد اسماء
شوارعهم على الرجل الذي اغتال اللي هو
الاسطنبولي اظن خارج الاسطنبولي اللي هو
انور السادات كل ده تاريخ
تعقدت العلاقه قطعت العلاقه كان ممكن في
مراحل لاحقه انه يتجاوزوا هذه العلاقه
ولكن كان في اعتبارات عند مصر واعتبارات
عند ايران الاعتبارات الايرانيه كثيره لكن
الحقيقه هم بيقولوا من وجهه نظرهم ان احدى
المعلن ان احنا راغبين في الخلاص تجاوزنا
المرحله دي وعايزين نطبع مع مصر لكن مصر
كان عندها مجموعه من الاعتبارات لعدم
التطبيع عدم التطبيع بمعنى ان يبقى في
تمثيل دبلوماسي كامل سفير هنا سفير هناك
علاقات طبيعيه سياحه بزنس الى اخره
السبب الاولاني هو الملف الامني
يعني مصر بتقول على مدار سنوات ان في
مطلوبين من الجانب المصري
ايران تحتفظ بهم وبتعتقد ان هي بتحتفظ بهم
لاسباب مشبوهه كوسيله للضغط ان دول اعضاء
في جماعات مصر بتعتبرها ارهابيه وايران
بتوفر لهم ماوى امن لهم وبتنكر ذلك ولكن
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه المصريه وحلفاء
مصريين برده اجازتهم الاستخباريه بتقول ان
هؤلاء
اثنين مراعاه الجانب الخليجي مصر حالفها
الاساسي هم الخليج والخليج كان في علاقته
شديده التوتر بايران فحتى ده برضو كانت
مصر بتاخده في الاعتبار ان هي اذا طبعت مع
ايران الخليجين سوف يشعروا يعني لن يحملوا
هذا الامر على محمل طيب يعني وهيعتبروها
ان مصر يعني باعتهم وان المساله ممكن تكون
مجرد يعني مش كانها بتطبع العلاقات معها
زي مثلا مع ليبيا لما كانت العلاقه مثلا
سيئه لا ده يعني امر صعب بالنسبه لهم على
الخليج تلاته انه
في ضغوط برضو شديده في فترات كارت العلاقه
ممكن يتم التطبيع يعني ممكن ايران في بعض
الفترات لان المساله مش ستاتيك يعني بتيجي
اداره هنا بتختلف عن اداره هناك اداره
خاتمه غير اداره نجاه احمد نجاد لكن كمان
كان في ضغوط من مش بس من دول الخليج ولكن
من الغرب يقول لمصر انت حليفه ليا ازاي
انت هتطبعي مع هذه الدوله
واحنا عندنا بيناتنا وبينهم ما يصنع
الحداد فمصر بتقولوا طب وانا عندي برضو
مصالح اوازل بينما يمكن ان احصل عليه من
الجانب الايراني وحجم الضرر الذي سوف
ياتيني من توتر علاقتي مع الخليج ومع
الغرب
الايام الاخيره ديت في امور تغيرت الخليج
بدا يطبع الغرب بدا
مش ضغوطه الضغوط موجوده ولكن دول عربيه
بدات تتجاوز هذه الضغوط لانه زي ما شفنا
دول كتيره بقت شايفه ان الامريكان يعني
صعب ان انت تسمع كلامهم في كل حاجه انا
لازم تتجاهلهم
انما لسه الملف الامني وبتفاوضوا عليه
ويبدو ان مصر عاوزه في مقابل هذا التطبيق
الذي تريده ايران اكبر مقابل ممكن وده
اللي بيحصل بين الدول لما هي تبدا تتفاوض
اتمنى ما اكونش اطلت عليك الاجابه قوي
اهلا ده سعيد نصري اهلا وسهلا اهلا بك يا
سعيد مساء الخير
يا ريت تكتبوا اساميكم لان الاسامي
بالانجليزي بتبقى مش دايم واضحه لي قوي هل
سيشارك الاسد في القمه العربيه تم دعوه ده
وهاب
وتم التوجيه الدعوه
بشار الاسد
يمكن ان يقبل الدعوه ويمكن ان ينيب عنه
شخص اخر لانه قد يرى انه من اللياقه انه
وجوده في ظل بعض الرفض من بعض الدول
العربيه قد يوتر الاجواء فالمساله هتخضع
للترتيبات اللي هي خلال الايام القليله
المقبله ممكن يحضر بنفسه
وقد ينيب عنه وزير خارجيه نائب رئيس وزراء
يعني شخصيه اخرى لكن انا حتى هذه اللحظه
لا اعلم على وجه اليقين ان كان سوف يحضر
بشخصه ام سوف يحضر من يروب عنه
اخونا
منين كنت بنطق اسمك اول مشاهد اتشرف
بحضرتك عبدو محمد تمام
ده حد تقريبا بيرد اذا كان الصوت تمام ولا
لا طيب هل يوجد نهايه لازمه سد النهضه ده
عمر والله يا عمر لا تبدو النهايه قريبه
لان التباعد بين المواقف الاثيوبيه
والمواقف المصريه
كبيره جدا وجت ازمه السودان عشان تعقد
المشهد اكثر لان ازمه السودان بتختصم من
القوه المصريه ومن القوه السودانيه وطبعا
بتصب في صالح اثيوبيا
الطالب الطليب انا ليبي مقيم في اوروبا
واتابعك من سنين ارجو الحديث عن الدور
الاسرائيلي الامريكي الحاسم في الحرب
السوريه عن طريق منع حصول المعارضه على
الاسلحه المضاده للطيران
الا توافقني في ذلك ارجو الرد يا استاذ
سيد يا صديقي القصه دي مش قصه امريكان
واسرائيليين دي قصه الروس انا كانت
معلوماتي منذ دخول الروس في 2015 الروس
قرروا ان هم يدخلوا الحرب اظن في سبتمبر
لما دخلوا كان هناك
يعني
رساله وصلت من الروس الى الجانب الامريكي
بالتحديد يعني اللي هو الزعيم للمعسكر
الغربي انا هدخل بطائراتي
وانتم بتايدوا المعارضه ما يعنيني في
المساله ردا على سؤالك ده الرؤوس ان انتم
لا تعطوا للمعارضه
اسلحه تسقط طائرات اذا فعلتم ذلك سوف ارد
عليكم في جبهات اخرى كثيره وسوف اصعد لان
هم تعلموا الدرس بتاع افغانستان لما دخل
الاتحاد السوفيتي ولم يتصرف بشكل حاسم
وكفر ومرح الجهاديون او الافغان او
المقاتلون
اسلحه مضاده للطيران واحداثه خسائر فادحه
في الجيش السوفيتي وقتها فالروس كانوا
مصرين ان هذا الخطوه اذا اقبل عليها
الامريكان او الاسرائيليون او اي طرف اخر
سوف يردون مثلا يعني بانه يمكن انه يزود
الايرانيين باسلحه متقدمه جدا فده مساله
مخيفه للامريكان يمكن ان يرد الامريكي
الروس باكثر من وسيله ما فيك دول امريكا
بتعتبرها مارقه وبتحريمها من كل انواع
السلاح المتطور فيروس كانوا بيهددوا بانهم
سوف يفعلون ذلك اذا اقبل الامريكان على
تزويد المعارضه باسلحه يمكن ان تسقط
مقاتلتهم
مش عارف اذا كنت جاوبت على سؤالك ولا
اه اهو اه هو يعني اه ماشي شكرا محمد
الوان نعم الصوت تمام شغل تمام ده الناس
كلهم بيرحموا بك عمرو احنا معنا النهارده
عمرو عمل انقلاب على ماندو واحنا ادركنا
انه كان في عنصر مؤامره بيتمثل في ماندو
فيتم الاطاحه مرحب صديقي
عمرو حجاج عمرو بيصور البرنامج من 2015 بس
النهارده بعد الانقلاب على ماندو وهو
معايا في المباشر وطبعا بين قوسين هذا
يعني من ضهرنا مريح بس
مساء الخير عمرو
احنا كده ايه الاسئله عندنا خلصت ولا ايه
انا قلت غلط معلش هرجع تاني لحظه كده انا
طلعت تاني عشان لو حد عدى سؤال وهرجع لكم
تاني بعد اذنكم محمود بيقول ماذا لو فاز
كلتش بالرئاسه كيف سيؤثر ذلك على وضع
ليبيا
اه ده سؤال صعب بس انا هقول لك على حاجه
محمود هو
يعني لما نيجي نشوف اولا
ما تكلمش على كل جزئيه في كل ملف وخيرا
فعل لانه لو دخل في التفاصيل قوي هيلزم
نفسه بوعود ربما لا يستطيع احد وانما
هاديك رد سريع على سؤال حضرتك وبعد كده
ممكن التفاصيل نتركها لو انت عاوز مزيد من
التفاصيل
قال انا عاوز كل حاجه ضد اردوغان
يعني العلاقه متوتره مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
انا عاوز اصلح العلاقه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي العلاقه متوتره مع امريكا
جيده مع الروس في عهد اردوغان لا انا شايف
ده هو بيقول يعني ان مصالحنا مع الامريكان
والغرب وحلف شمال الاطلاق وحلف شمال
الاطلسي
وهكذا في قضايا اخرى لكن اهم اهم نقطه
تحدث عنها تقترب من اجابه سؤال حضرتك انه
قال ان انا عاوز اعود فعلا الى الى
الوسائل الدبلوماسيه في
معالجه قضايا الجيران في اشاره الى الدول
العربيه انا عاوز الامور تبقى بالحسنى
عاوز قضايا الجران تشمل ليبيا تشمل
ارمينيا اذربيجان تشمل سوريا تشمل قضايا
كثيره قال انا عاوز اعالجها بالطريقه
الدبلوماسيه الهادئه بعيدا عن استخدام
السلاح ما يعني
انه هيكون اكثر رغبه في انه يتفاوض على
المصالح التركيه بدون استخدام السلاح انت
سن له ذلك
هل يمكن ان تختفي الدول الخليج في حال
وقوع حرب اقليميه علي ليه علي اختفى الدول
الخليج دول الخليج
يعني كتله كبيره وبنتكلم على حوالي 60
مليون خليجي وبنتكلم على دول عندها رفاهيه
اقتصاديه وعندهم مصالح دول كثيره عندهم
هذا غير وارد يعني مش منطقي الا اذا كنا
بنتكلم على حرب عالميه وفي الحاله ديت مش
بس الدول الخليج لا قدر الله ولكن دول
كثيره لا قدر الله هتبقى معرضه لخراب كبير
لكن دوله حرب اقليميه يعني هتعمل ايه
هتتضرر دول الخليج لانها هي هتكون في مرمى
نيران يعني لكن مش الى درجه ان هي تتدمر
وما تنساش ان مره حروب اقليميه
وتعرضت لها دول الخليج تضررت لكن مش الى
حد ان هي تختفي
ماذا لو فاز كلتشنر اوغلو اجابنا ما رايك
بما تقوم به السعوديه بخصوص التضامن
والتوحد والتكامل العربي وهل ترى مستقبل
واستمراريه لهذا النكد علاء
ما هو لو رجعنا لحلقه اللي هو اظن كان
الحلقه اللي بتكلم فيها عن المصالحه مع
ايران اللي هي الاسباب الثلاثه التي دعت
السعوديه للتطبيع مع ايران والحلقه اللي
هي قبل الاخيره اظن عن كواليس التطبيع مع
الاسد يعني انا اشرت فيها الى النهجه اللي
هي بتتبع السعوديه بدايه من
يعني اخر 2020 اول 21
في تغير في السياسه السعوديه خلاصته ان هي
ادركت انه اسلوب المواجهه الخشنه في
المنطقه اللي هي جربته بالفعل لم يجدي
نفعا وبالتالي بدات تتبع اساليب اللي هي
الاساليب الهادئه والدبلوماسيه ومحاوله
التهدئه عشان تحافظ على مصالحها
الاقتصاديه وعلشان تقدر انه يتدفق
ميترولها في امان وتقدر ان هي تبني
مشاريعها الصينيين مثلا كان عندهم قلق ان
انا عاوز استثمر مليارات الدولارات في
السعوديه فمش معقوله صاروخ من الحوثيين
يعمل لي قلق السعوديين يستثمروا في
السياحه مش ممكن يستثمروا في السياحه اذا
كانت الدرونز ممكن تزعجهم طوال الوقت زي
موقف
الاماراتيين يعني ودول الخليج بصفه عامه
وبالتالي بدات عمليه التهادئه
هي المرحله دي فعلا انا مره عملت حلقه
قصيره يعني دقيقه ده كان مقترح ماندو وهو
مقترح يعني
ما نجحش خالص قال لي لو عملت لو عملت
مقاطع قصيره يعني يعني الناس هتبقى مبسوطه
الناس رد فعلهم كان سيء جدا
لكن هي الحلقه كان اسمها يعني ايه كلمه
ديطانت في السياسه الدوليه استاذنكم اذا
ما كانش عندكم مانع نخصص لكلمه ديت حلقه
هي تاريخيا يعني ايه وازاي بتنطبق الكلمه
دي تشرح لنا المرحله اللي احنا فيها
[موسيقى]
الى الى يزيد من
الى
يزيد هذا من فوائد الديون انا لم افهم
السؤال يا كروان يعني الى يزيد انا مش
فاهم السؤال عدنان ساهر بيقول السلام
عليكم من ترش من ترشح الرئيس بعد القادم
من الشخصيات السياسيه التركيه الحاليه
بعد القادم طب احنا عندنا مشكله في القادم
الاول ما هو اصل انت خلال خمس سنوات على
الارجح يعني بنسبه 60 70 80% هيكون
اردوغان
ففي خلال خمس سنوات شخصيات لامعه الان زي
مثلا
امام اوغلو محافظ اسطنبول زي محافظ انقره
زي شخصيات اخرى قد تزداد معنا وقد تخفض
احنا شفنا شخصيات اختفت في لحظه فيديو
واحد مخل اطار برئيس حزب
حزب الشعب يعني
الحزب الجمهور يا اصول اصحبي تماما
وبالتالي فضيحه ماليه فضيحه اخلاقيه اي
حاجه من الحاجات دي وبالتالي خلال خمس
سنوات امور كتيره قد تتغير
ده ممكن يتغير ما هو اكثر يعني اصل
اردوغان اللي احنا بنتكلم عليه هو حكم
عشرين سنه اذا نجح هيقعد خمس سنوات اخرى
وده المفروض وفقا للدستور بعد تعديله ده
اخر فتره ممكن يترشح ما تندهش يعني اذا
حصل تغيير ثاني في الدستور وبقى لسنوات
وهو عنده 67 سنه بعد خمس سنوات ثلاثه
وسبعين سنه ممكن يعمل زي رؤساء اخرين او
زي ما عمل قبل كده في تركيا ويبقى لسنوات
فبعد سنه ثلاث خمس سنوات الله اعلم
محمود متحمس للسؤال وطرحه كثيرا اجبناك يا
استاذ محمود
[موسيقى]
احنا بنقول ايه
طيب
ماشي تحيه لك استاذ سيد جبيل ما رايك في
رجب اردوغان وهل فعلا نهض بتركيا نهضه
حضاريه واقتصاديه ده الواثق بالله يا
استاذ واثق بالله
الاسئله اللي هي بتبقى تقييميه ديت بتبقى
اسئله صعبه الاجابه عليها
لانها اسئله
يعني ما تقدرش مثلا ايه انا لما اجي اوصف
صديقي عمرو حجاج اللي قدامي هنا وقول طوله
وكذا عرض وكذا وزنه كذا دي ومش اكتف لكن
لما تقول لي مثلا هو طيب ولا شرير طب هو
كفؤ ولا الحاجات دي فيها كثير من يعني من
الانحيازيه او عدم الموضوعيه لكن اما وقد
قلت ذلك فالاجابه السريعه والبسيطه هو انه
هذا سياسي استثنائي في تاريخ تركيا له
انجازاته ضخمه جدا لا ينكرها الا يعني
[موسيقى]
الا موتور واحد يكون مصر يعني لاي سبب
عنده مشاكل مع اردوغان
وانا شخصيا كان عندي مشكله مع اردوغان
شخصيه مش شخصيه بمعنى مباشر يعني ولكن انا
احد اصدقائي الاتراك زوج به في السجن
لاسباب منها ان هو ان هو اجرى حوار معي
اتمنى انه يكون خرج من السجن
ويعني انا شعرت بصدمه بالنسبه لي كبيره
جدا انه يتعرض في السجن لانه قال كلام حكم
بسببه بعد كده في تركيا ولكن دي قصه يطول
شرحها لكن لكن في مقابل الانجازات العظيمه
اللي عملها اردوغان الرجل ايضا ارتكب
اخطاء كبيره داخل تركيا
وسياساته
الداخليه اولا خصوصا بعد الانقلاب الفاشل
في 2016 عادت عدد كبير من الاتراك واحنا
بنتكلم تقريبا نص الشعب التركي مش عاوزه
بس هي كده الديمقراطيه لكن النص زائد واحد
مش واحد يعني 51% 50% زائد بني ادم واحد
هو الاوقاف السلطه وحتى لما بيقل عن 50%
يعني 48 و46
بيكملهم بتحالف فيما المعارضه بتفشل ان هي
تعمل ده ارتكب اخطاء كتيره داخليه وارتكب
اداره واخطاء خارجيه في فتح جبهات مع كل
الدول ما كانش فيه سبب وجيه قوي يعني
لمعاداته للسعوديه وللامارات
وطبعا لمصر ولا فرنسا وللغرب كتير جدا دخل
في معارك كثيره جدا النتيجه انها انعكست
سلبا على الاقتصاد التركي لكن لانه هو
سياسي بطبعه يعني حاوي بارع جدا هو قدر
انه يستبق الانتخابات بانه
للخلف ضر يعالج اكبر عدد ممكن من المشاكل
فاضل له مشكله انه يعيد النظر في السياسات
الاقتصاديه الغريبه جدا التي اضرت
بالاقتصاد التركي الفائده وما الفائده
ممكن ترجعوا يعني لها فممكن يقدر يتجاوز
هذه الاخطاء في الخمس سنوات اذا نجح يعني
ام لادي قصه بقى لننظر ونرى لكن الاجابه
المختصره جدا وسياسي استثناء له انجازات
عظيمه وله اخطاء عظيمه مثل سياسيين الكبار
لماذا في الدول الديمقراطيه ده محمد جمال
علي النادي لماذا في الدول الديمقراطيه
التي فيها حكم القانون يمتلك رئيس الدوله
حق اعطاء عفو رئاسي لاحد المواطنين الا
يعتبر هذا انتهاك لمبدا حكم القانون لانه
يمكن ان يعفو عن احد اقاربه موجود صحيح
موجود في ايه وطبعا الولايات المتحده مثال
بارز على ذلك
هم بيفترضوا ان رئيس الدوله هو برضو العفو
اصلا مش بيطلع مثلا يعني
اخته
وزوج خالته وكده يعني بتبقى فيها ضوابط
وفيها يعني انما هو بيفترض ان احيانا
القضايا السياسيه هو مش واحد محكوم عليه
مثلا ارتكب جريمه وانه سرق بنك او سرق بيت
او قتل شخص فيقول له انا هصدر عنك عفو هو
العفو بيكون عاده في القضايا السياسيه
اللي فيها درجه كثير من عمليه التقدير
القضايا اللي فيها بعد دولي واحد قبض عليه
في قضيه تجسس بس صالح البلد دي ان هو
مصلحه بلده ان هم يعرفوا عن هذا الجاسوس
علشان يستردوا مثلا اسرى او رهائن او يعني
اخرين بتبقى عمليه تقديريه يعني في الغالب
لكن طبعا الاجابه الافضل تيجي من حد بقى
من اساتذه القانون الدستوري انا عندي فكره
عامه كده لكن التفاصيل ليست لديهم
هل التطبيع السعودي الاسرائيلي قريب لا
ليس قريبا ده علي ما رايك بما اعجبنا
السؤال عن السعوديه جابنا الخليج حد عامل
كده يعني مبسوط ماشي
ماشي اجبنا
ماشي اجبنا اجبنا
في اسئله متكرره كتير قوي
اجابنا
استاذ سيد ما رايك ده الوثق بالله تاني
استاذ سيد ما رايك لو انتصرت الثوره
السوريه وماذا كانت يؤثر ذلك على سوريا
وكل المنطقه اذا نجحت الثوره السوريه او
اذا نجح المعارضون السوريون
واسقطوا الرئيس بشار الاسد وجاؤوا الى
السلطه كان هتبقى فيه سيناريوهات كثيره
جدا
اول هذه يتوقف على من سوف يصل الى السلطه
وهيصلها بعد قد ايه هو بدعم من يعني
السيناريو اللي كانوا يتخيلوا انه يعني
مثلا اردوغان مثلا كان عنده تصور انه
جماعات
ده تتوجه اسلامي تقدي او تسقط بشار الاسد
وياتي الى راس السلطه شخص محسوب من هذه
الجامعات يعني تقريبا من جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين محسوبا على جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وتبقى زي ما كانت تخيله ان هذا
سوف يحدث في مصر في تونس في المغرب في دول
كثيره وبالتالي هيكون قريب الى طبعا الى
تركيا اذا نجح المخطط الخليجي كان هتنجح
الجماعات وهياتي رجل من جماعات المعارضه
القريب من دول الخليج وبالتالي يعتمد
عليهم في اعاده الاعمار وفي مواجهه فلول
بشار الاسد ويقطع العلاقات ايوتر العلاقات
مع ايران وهكذا كل اذا جاء حد بقى من
المعارضه المرضي عليها من المصريين او من
الامريكان كل على حسب من يدعمه لكن كنت
عاوز اؤكد لك على حاجه انه الان الوضع جدا
في سوريا
وكان اصعب ايام الاقتتال للاسف علمنا
التاريخ انه ايضا
يعني اسقاط نظام بالقوه له تكلفته وكان
هتبقى المساله ليست سلسه كما يتخيل البعض
لانه انت بتتكلم على دول
يعني مش بتتكلم على انه
مثلا معارضه دي مش بتعبر عن صحيح اغلبيه
ساحقه وان هي لو كانت بتعبر عن اغلبيه
ساحقه واستطاعت ان تنتصر على نظام
يعني خلاص ضعف وذهبوا كانت الامور تبقى
سهله بس وضحنا على الارض وانه بشار الاسد
نجح بشكل او باخر في ان يجير في
[موسيقى]
ان يقنع باس بها من السوريين وخصوصا من
اصحاب النفوذ انه يبقوا على الاقل خارج
المعادله ان لم يكونوا مؤيدين لهم
وبالتالي كانت المساله هتكون دمويه
هي مارس للمغرب ما السبب ومتى على المنطقه
تحياتي دكتور تقصدي يعني صواريخ يمارس انا
ما قريتش انه هم خدوا صواريخ هي مارس بس
مش هندهش انهم ياخدوها المغرب حليف مهم
للدول الغربيه وهي حريصه ان هي تسلح نفسها
باكبر قدر ممكن من الاسلحه بصراحه اولا هي
عندها كدوله عاوزه تحصل على سلاح خاربك
مؤثر يعني او مهم
الحاجه التانيه ان خصمها الاساسي او
جارتها الجزائر بتنفق انفاقا ضخما جدا على
التسليح وبتستطيع ان تحصل من الروس على
اسلحه متطوره فكلما حصلت الجزائر على
منظومه تسليح متطوره من الروس او من
الصينيين يسعى المغاربه لاقناع الجانب
الغربي ومؤخرا اسرائيل
ببيعهم منظومات اسلحه لا تقل تطورا بس انا
لم اقرا عن مسالته مارس او صواريخ هي مارس
لكنها منظومه صواريخ فمش هكون غريبه هم
بيتفاوضوا على ما هو اكثر هم يعني عاوزين
ياخذوا اف 35 وما تنساش انه تقارير غربيه
محترمه في مصادر محترمه قالت ان المغرب
ارسل اسلحه يعني سمح للامريكان ان يشتروا
دبابات اظن
وتم ارسالها الى شركه كافيه لتقوم
بتطويرها وارسالها للجبهه الاوكرانيه
فهذا امر يعني سوف تحمله الاداره
الامريكيه بكثير من الامتنان ويجب ان ترد
هذا الجميل
صالح مصر من الخليج اهم واكبر وسبوبه كمان
ده نجتلي لا كلمه سبوبه مش كلمه مناسبه يا
اخونا العزيز هي بصالح بين دول
واهم واكبر ماشي هو يقصد ان مصالح مصر مع
الخليج اهم واكبر من ايران طبعا ديكتات
الحسابات المصريه
انما كان في جانب تاني بيقول طب وايه
التناقض اصلا يعني هو اصل هو المصالح مش
متطابقه ما الذي كان يمنع المصريين يعني
ان هم يقيموا علاقه طيبه مع الايرانيين
ويكونوا همزه وصل بين الايرانيين وبين
الاليين في وجهات نظر كثيره فيما يتعلق
بالشان الايراني
ويعني انا اصلا اتكلمت في المساله كثيرا
حتى يعني انزعج الكثيرون انا وجهت نظري
كانت وما زالت واظن بفضل الله انه احيانا
الله حتى رايت انه الكلام المتواضع اللي
انا بقوله من سنين ما كانش كله غلط يعني
في ناس كانوا بيقولوا لي انت واهم يعني
انه المانع ان احنا نتعايش مع الايرانيين
يعني احنا تعايشنا مع الاسرائيليين
واتعايشنا مع الاتراك في الفتره الاخيره
وكانوا احتلوا شمال سوريا واحتلوا جزء من
العراق
وارسلوا قوتهم الى ليبيا وفي تعايش يعني
مش
والخارجين تعيشوا مع ايران واحنا تعايشنا
معهم فيعني
تتعاي مش معناها ان انت تسلم ليه بس دي
قصه تكلمنا عنها كثيرا وكانوا مازال رايي
في رايي انا بتكلم بعض المسؤولين في مصر
بصراحه مش مسئولين
لان المسؤولين على الملف انا مش قادره
افهمه فيما يتعلق بمصر ايران ولكن بعض
المطلعين على الامر
هم بيعتقدوا ان الخلافات المصريه
الايرانيه تناقضات كبيره ولا قنعت ان هي
التناقضات موجوده يعني خلافات ولكنها لا
تصل الى الحد ان احنا نستمر في قتل
العلاقات التفسير الوحيد ان العلاقات
انقطعت ولم تتسنى الظروف او لم تسمح
الظروف باستعادتها بثمن مقبول من المصريين
تمام ممكن استاذن بس الاصدقاء تكرار
السؤال كثير كثيرا يعني مثلا 10 و 12 و15
مره بيبقى مجهد ليا وبيخليني ما اشوفش
اسئله تانيه اهم
الاسئله متكرره كتير قوي يا عمرو
واحد اسمه
طيب هل صحيح ان بريطانيا
ده اخونا رف
جبال الريف هل صحيح ان بريطانيا اصبحت
دوله فقيره لا ما اصبحتش دوله فقيره اصبحت
دوله عندها مشاكل في اقتصادها
ندي المحلي لبريطانيا اعاده سكان بريطانيا
في حدود 50 60 مليون مواطن يعني
والناتج المحلي لها حوالي اثنين وسبعه من
عشره تريليون يعني زي ما قلت لحضراتكم ما
زال اقتصادها قد تقريبا اقتصاد كل الدول
العربيه من الخليج الى المحيط
والمواطن البريطاني النصيبه من المحلي
الاجمالي من الدول المرفهه وما زالت دوله
عندها قدرات سياحيه مهوله عندها قدرات
عسكريه عندها قدرات صناعيه عندها كتير لكن
هو مواطن مرفه فلما بيشعر ان عنده ازمه
اقتصاديه وان انفاق الحكومه يعني هينخفض
وانه مش هياخد تامين صحي مفتوح او يعني
سخن زي ما كان معتاد وانه المرافق مش
هينفق عليها بنفس القدر وانه يعني كل
الحاجات اللي اعتاد عليها المواطن
البريطاني وانه
القدره الشرقيه للاستيرليني هتنخفض بتبقى
عمليه نسبيه بيشعر بانه في ازمه كبيره هي
مش ازمه كبيره زي ازمه تونس زي ازمه مصر
زي
طبعا زي ازمه السودان ولكن معناه ان هم
اصبحوا اقل
مما كانوا عليه وان الافاق في المستقبل
ليست كما كانت حين كانوا طبعا امبراطوريه
ولا حتى حين كانوا جزءا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ما تعليقكم على التطورات في
لحظه واحده يا شباب
ما تعليقكم على
التطورات في السودان واثر ذلك على ازمه سد
النهضه وما هي احتمالات الحل العسكري بعد
تصريحات الوزير سامح شكري على ان مصر
لنذهب مجددا لمجلس الامن وانا الاتحاد
الافريقي
انا ما اعرفش تصريحات الوزير سامح شكري
انه لن يذهب مجددا لمجلس الامن ماشي ولكن
انت عندك سؤالين التطورات في السودان طبعا
مؤسفه جدا لانه تعثرت جهود الوساطه حتى
الان الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه
وتعثرت قبلها محاولات من جهات مختلفه
افريقيه ودوليه ما كانش في محاوله جاده
قوي سوى المحاوله السعوديه الامريكيه لكن
يعني لم تنجح حتى هذه اللحظه وساءت وساءت
الاوضاع او تدهورت الاوضاع وزاره
الاشتباكات على الاقل حتى قبل دخولي الى
الاستديو
وبالتالي احنا ماشيين في نفس السيناريو
بتاع الحروب الاهليه اللي حصلت في السودان
مرارا بقى في الثمانينات في يعني كان في
صراعات متعدده من 83 الف
الحرب الانفصال انتهت به او حرب الشمال
والجنوب اللي انتهى بانفصال الجنوب في
2011 نفس الدائره شغاله بتبدا المعارك
عنيفه جدا كل طرف عاوز يحسمها في اسرع وقت
ثم يدرك ان الحسم العسكري صعب يبتدي يبحث
عن شركاء الشركاء دول بيبدا بالقوه
المحليه القوه المحليه بتبدا تدخل مع طرف
فتستفز قوه اخرى تتسع الحرب فيشمل البلد
كله
احيانا بتاخد كمان بعد طائفي بيخلي الحرب
اكثر دمويه انه احد الاطراف تورط فيه
استهداف فئه او يعني عرق معين او قبيله
معينه بالخطا او
بالقصد يعني اشتعل الحرب اكثر مع اشتعال
الحرب في كامل الاقليم للاسف بتدخل
الاطراف خارجيه وهكذا فللاسف احنا كان كل
الناس اللي بيكلموني ولو بتفتكروا الحلقه
الاولانيه اللي عملناها عن السودان ماذا
يجري في السودان بياكدوا لي ان المساله
خلال ايام وانا كنت بقول لكم هذا تفاؤل
يعني لا طلع متفائل شديد احنا عدينا الشهر
ولا يبدو ان هناك حلا في الافق
احنا لسه في مرحله امل كل طرف انه يحسمها
بالقوه العسكريه
ده ياثر قد ايه على سد النهضه انا اجبت في
اول الحلقه انه طبعا تاثيره سيء لانه خصما
من قوه مصر وقوه السودان وبعدين مصر هتعمل
ايه في مجلس الامن مع مصر راحت مجلس الامن
ولجات الى وسطات اوروبيه وانا بساطه غربيه
ولم تنجح هذه الوساطات
بثانه اذا كنت بنطق الاسم صح ارجو الاجابه
المباشره حسب وجهه نظرك كم تحتاج الصين
لتجاوز الولايات المتحده في ايه تتجاوزها
هي تتجاوزتها من حيث الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي
بالمعادل القوه الشرائيه يعني الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للولايات المتحده 25
مليار دولار الناتج المحلي للصين بيقتمن
اسف 25 تريليون دولار ناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للصين حوالي عشرين تريليون دولار
بمعادل القوه الشرعيه ما يمكن ان يشتريه
ليوان في الصين وما يمكن ان يشتريه
الدولار في الولايات المتحده الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للصين حوالي 30 تريليون
دولار واحد من المعايير فيبقى الصين تجاوز
امريكا بهذا المعيار نصيب الفرد من الدخله
القومي لصالح الولايات المتحده
لانه عدد الولايات المتحده حوالي 330 340
مليون مواطن وعدد الصين
يعني مليار
و400 تقريبا
مليون يعني فطبعا نصيب الفرد اقل بكثير
بالنسبه لقطع التسليح الصين تفوقت في قطع
التسليح لكن بعض الخبراء بيقولوا ان ما
زالت الكواليتي او الجوده او القوه
التدميريه والتطور لصالح الولايات المتحده
الصين تفوقت على الصين في الابحاث
عدد
الابراءات الاختراع والابحاث العلميه
المسجله بدايه من 21 انما لسه ده الاجابه
يعني على حسب انت تسنى تتجاوزها في ايه
لكن ما زالت الولايات المتحده هي القوه
والعظمى والاقوى
يعني اجمالا يعني لانه في اعتبارات يعني
انا
مش عارف يعني انا عندي بنتي بتدرس مثلا
لغه صينيه فطول الوقت بتتكلم على الصين
يعني اكتشفت امبارح مثلا بتكلمني على بعض
اصدقائها من الصينيات بيقول لي ان هم
عندهم مشكله كبيره جدا في التواصل مع
العالم الخارجي بسبب عائق اللغه دي مشكله
قد تبدو
يعني شكليه بس مش شكليه ما انت محتاج انك
انت تكون لغتك واصله لاكبر عدد من الناس
من النعم الله على الامريكان ان لغتهم ايه
الانجليزي وبالتالي ما عندوش اي مشكله انه
يحل في اي مكان يتواصل مع الناس افلامه
وبتوصل لكل مكان منتجاته اطباء وجامعاته
وطبعا عملته الدولار ديت مخلياه يعني يعني
اوجه التفوق الامريكي ما زالت واضحه في
انما المؤكد برضو بقدر ما الامريكان ما
زالوا اكثر تفوقا بشكل واضح ان الفجوه
بتضيق يوما بعد يوم حتى هذه اللحظه
انا مش فاهم يا فهد انت قصدك ايه نريد
حلقه عن الاقتصاد
السهم ما اعرفش يعني ايه يمكن انت كتبت
حاجه غلط
اخونا الطليب اجبت عليه
صفقه على الغرب انه يكشف لهم مواقع وجود
الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا وقالوا ان ده
تدليس من الجانب الغربي فالحقيقه هي مساله
مثيره للفضول ولكن لا املك ولا اعتقد ان
في حد يملك على وجه اليقين
الخلافات دي حقيقيه ولا مصطنعه
برضو يعني مش عارف انا اللي بشوف الاسئله
مكرره جدا جدا اول مره يعني دي طيب محمد
العتيبي وزير الخارجيه السوري اليوم اكد
حضور الاسد للقمه طب والله ده خبر ما
عرفوش انت
اخونا محمد العتيبي بيقول انه قرا
النهارده في النشرات او انه الاسد سوف
يحضر
لماذا في الدول الديمقراطيه اجابنا هل
فعلا المخابرات المصريه تساعد الحرس
الثوري في ايصال الصواريخ لغزه عبر سيناء
مين اللي ممكن يعرف الاجابه على كده يا
اخونا جيجي لانه اذا يعني علاقه الحرس
الثوري
بقطع غزه هي بالغه السريه العلاقات اجهزه
المخابرات اذا كانت تتعاون مع الجانب
الايراني لهذا الامر هتكون بالغه السريه
لا اعلم
لا اعلم الحقيقه
ولو عندي معلومات لو قلتها يعني لو عندي
معلومات تبقى غير مؤكده ولا قلتها ممكن
يعني تبقى يعني
يعني الافضل اللي انا ما اقولش حاجه الا
لما اكون واثق منها ان هي تكون معلومات
مؤكده فعلا وما اعرفش ان في حد عنده
معلومات مؤكده في هذا الصلاه
مساء الخير محمد محمود بيقول مساء الخير
تعتقد من الافضل لمصر اردوغان اللي بدا
يغير سياسته في مصر ولا اوغلو والله
الاتنين صيام دلوقتي لانه
واردوغان يعني ما هي المعارضه كانت عاوزه
تهزم اردوغان في ملفات منه اللي هم من
زمان بيقولوا انت ليه تغضب دوله زي مصر
عشان اصدقائك الاخوان فكانوا بياخذوا هذا
الجانب على على اردوغان وبذات ينتمي الى
حزب بالغ حزب اللي اسسه مصطفى كمال
اتاتورك حزب علماني يعني
موغل في العلمانيه ايه اللي حصل كل شيطان
اوغلو ابتدى يخفف من موقفه العلمانيه
ويقرب شويه
للجماهير اللي هي عندها توجه اسلامي وطبعا
اردوغان بدا قبل الانتخابات يخفف من وقفه
ويستدير ويغير كثير من مواقفه النتيجه
دلوقتي تقريبا قريبا يتوقف طبعا بقى على
الميول يعني بعض السياسيين اكيد يعني الود
مفقود شويه لو انت بتتكلم على اللي هياخد
القرار مصر هنا الرئيس السيسي وهناك
الرئيس التركي اكيد يعني الود بينهم ما
هواش عظم زي ما اكيد يعني انه اكيد
القياده المصريه تتمنى لو تبدا يعني مع
شخص يكون العلاقه اسلس معاه لكن دي عواطف
في الحالتين الاتنين تقريبا بيتساوى بما
انه اردوغان غير سياسته اتجاه مصر واتجاه
الامارات واتجاه السعوديه وهكذا يعني
يا اخونا محمد جمال علي النادي انت طرحت
السؤال تقريبا
25 مره يعني فانا يعني
اكون لو يعني ميرسي هتخليني اقدر اركز مع
بقيه الاسئله يعني اذا كنت عاوز تعاقبني
لاي سبب يعني
راي حضرتك في كلاوش ويب اللي هو كلاوشوا
بالاقتصادي
الالماني اللي اسس منتدى نافوس يعني مش
عاوز اقول كلمه مش مناسبه يعني انا التقيت
انا كنت بسافر يعني بحكم عملي القديم نورد
بشكل متكرر هو
بيعمل بيزنس كويس يعني هو خلاص يعني هيبقى
وورد كويس بيروح في كل بلد بيثني على
القاده بيثني على رجال الاعمال يعني عنده
بيزنس جيد يعني ما عنديش راي في الحقيقه
خاص غير ان انا لاحظت هذا يعني
ما عندوش يعني مثلا مقدمش افكار عظيمه قوي
ممكن مثلا تتوقف عندها على الاقل في
السنوات الاخيره يعني
وعلاء برضو من فضلك يا علاء انا اجبني
السؤال فيما يتعلق بالسعوديه برضو
ميدو بيقول ماذا سيحدث لمصر اقتصاديا لو
اصرت على عدم ايقاف المشاريع القوميه
وتحايلت على شروط البنك هل دخلت مصر في
كاسات مع وجود اخبار حول تراجع بين اللحوم
مثلا بنسبه 85% ودي ارقام شبه حكوميه لو
اصرت يعني انت بتقول لو اصرت على استكمال
المشاريع القوميه هي بالتالي صعب ان هي
تصر مشاريع القوميه دي عاوزه اموال اذا
كانت الاموال بقت فيها ازمه وفي مشاكل وفي
مشاكل سيوله الاصرار هنا هيكون معناه
عمليه انتحار يعني فاكيد ما فيش سياسي
عاوز انه ينتحر سياسيا ثم المساله ما هياش
مساله شخصيه وهم اعلنوا انه
انه هيحصل
عدم البدء في مشروعات قوميه كبرى ومحاوله
استكمال المشروعات اللي هم خلاص قطعوا شوط
كبير فيها يعني لانه كده الخساره هتبقى
كبيره قطع وشوط كبير وفي عقود وفي شركات
ففي حدود معلوماتي ان هم بيستكملوا
المشروعات ذات التكلفه المنخفضه زي بعض
الطرق وبعض الاصلاحات وهكذا يعني او
المشروعات اللي هم تقريبا قطعوا معظمها
يعني
قطعوا شوط كبير فيها
انت بتقول مصر ده دخلت في ركود اصل الركود
ده لتعريف علمي الركود ان انت يبقى عندك
النمو يبقى بالسالب لمده
ربعين سنويا ست اشهر حتى هذه اللحظه بهذه
المعايير هذا لم يحدث انما الازمه موجوده
يعني بغض النظر انه النمو لم يتحقق ما انت
لسه كنت بتاخد قروض ولسه البرلمان موافق
على قرض باثنين مليار يورو وده امر عجيب
غريب
يعني يضع علامات استفهام يعني ايه الاصرار
يعني ممكن يكون عندها وجهه نظر انا مش
عارفها ايه وجهه نظرها ولكن ما هو المشروع
بتاع القطار السريع اظن اللي اخذه علشان
بننتظر عام مثلا
فمش عارف ايه فكره الضرر الكبير اللي
هيكون موجود طبعا ممكن تعرف لانه كان وزير
النقل موجود في البرلمان لكن انا لم استمع
الى الكلمه اللي هو قالها والتبريراته
احمد بيقول هل في اعتقاد حضرتك ممكن
الولايات المتحده تتخلف عن سداد
التزاماتها بالدولار كلها بالدولار هي ما
عندهاش عمله محليه في حاله الخلاف السياسي
بين الرئيس والكونجرس
احمد انا مقتنع يعني مساله رفع سقف الدين
هي بصراحه فيلم امريكي هوليودي بامتياز
علشان نضع الامور في نصابها هناك خلاف بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين داخل الكونجرس
على رقف على رفع سقف الدين وعلشان
الاصدقاء يكونوا معنا في الصوره لو ما
كانش عندهم فكره الحكومه الامريكيه بتقترب
زي اي حكومه لانه
دخلها اقل من انفاقها فاللي بيحصل ان هي
بتنفق لكن الحكومه الامريكيه من 1917
اخترعت قانون او سنه قانون كانت تعتقد انه
سوف يمنح الحكومه مرونه ان هي تقول لها
عندك سقف انا سوف اقره تقتردي دونه علشان
ما تجيليش لان الحكومات التانيه بتعمل ايه
بتقر موازنه وبعدين بتعمل حساب ختامي كده
انا هعقد الاجابه يعني الحكومات الاخرى
بترجع لمجلس الشعب في كل قرار بتقترضه
عشان ما ترجعليش كل شويه انا هعمل لك سقف
عام اصرفي منه ونتفاهم يعني ما تتجاوزهوش
اللي حاصل ان هذا السقف اللي هو كان اخر
مره اكرر بواحد وتلاتين ونقول لاختصارا 31
تريليون و400 مليار خلاص تم تجاوزه اظن من
اول يناير او منتصف يناير الماضي
وبداوا يتحايلوا على المساله دي انه
محتاجين ان هم
تم التجاوزهم مؤخرا انا اسف انا مش متاكد
من التاريخ يمكن احنا فين في جون تم
تجاوزه مؤخرا ومنذ فتره بيقولوا ان احنا
محتاجين
اعتمادات جديده من الكونجرس لمزيد من
الاقتراض انا بقول بالتالي لازم الكونجرس
وافق والا كده خلاص الكشخ خلص قالت انه هي
انفخ خلال ايام دي وزيره الخزانه ومش
هيبقى قادره واصل الانفاق على بقى رواتب
الموظفين وعلى اوجه الانفاق المختلفه
تعليم ودفاع والى اخره ليه بقول انه
ده فيلم امريكي لانه الكلام ده بيحصل
تقريبا كل سنه يعني لما تشوف تاريخ السقف
الدين الامريكي ده هتلاقي
لسه كانت وزاره الخزانه كاتبه بتقول ان
سنه 60 78 مره حصل اعاده النظر في هذا
السقف بشكل او باخر لما تيجي تشوف من 1917
هتلاقيهم تقريبا 67 مره
طرحوا هذا السقف للتفاوض وفي النهايه هم
ما عندهمش حل تاني اللي هيحصل انه ايه
الحزب اللي في المعارضه اللي هو
الجمهوريين مش من مصلحته انه الحزب اللي
في السلطه يبقى مطلق الصراحه ينفق زي ما
هو عاوز لانه لو انفخ زي ما هو عاوز هيخلق
حاله من الرضا بين المواطنين
تخليهم راغبين في اعاده انتخاب الحزب اللي
في السلطه اللي هو الديمقراطي
فبالتالي بيضيقوا عليه علشان تغلي ايده
فيحصل عمليه سخط يمهد لهم الوصول الى
السلطه
وعليه كل حزب دايما لما بيكون موجود
بيحاول انه يفرد هذا السقف ويتشدد فيه
وبيحصل عمليه مفاوضات هم يوافقوا
للجمهوريين على شيء
والعكس يحصل فيحصل عمليه تنازل ولازم
يوافقوا ليه لازم يوافقوا لانه التكلفه
هتكون كارثيه اذا لم يوافق الكونجرس
وبالتالي يتوقف تتوقف المؤسسات الامريكيه
وتتخلف الحكومه عن سد ديونها ويفقد العالم
الثقه
تفقد المؤسسات الامريكيه اللي بتسلف
الحكومه الامريكيه الثقه يعني انا بنك
النهارده في امريكا وبسلف الحكومه
الامريكيه تقول لي انا مش هسدد في الموعد
والاقي نفسي عندي مشكله مع زبائني انا مش
هسلف الحكومه الامريكيه تاني الحكومات
الخارجيه لم تقرضها وبالتالي قطعا حتى ولو
تاخروا عن الموعد
اسبوع اثنين ثلاثه شهر لازم يحصل عمليه
التفاوض تؤدي الى رفع سقف الدين انما
المشكله اللي محدش بيتكلم عنها وبيتكلموا
عنها بس ما حدش بيهتم بها زي كل المشاكل
اللي هي طبيله الامد النهارده الثقه في
الدين الامريكي وتتجاوز الديون الامريكيه
بكثير ال 31 تريليون و400 مليون دولار
وتبقى زي مثلا 32 33 35 يعني تجاوزت المئه
في المئه بكثير والميه وعشره والميه
وعشرين من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ما هي
الولايات المتحده هتبقى عندها مشكله كل
الامبراطوريات اللي ضعفت نتيجه
تراقب الديون عليها
وبالتالي في مشكله سواء
رفعوا سقف الدين او لم يرفعه هم لازم
يرفعه على كل الاحوال
ماذا تفعل ايران في مشروعها التوسعي بعد
المصالحه مع السعوديه محمد العتيبي وهو
محمد
انا مش متاكد ان ايران عندها مشروع
ايدولوجي هو نفس الموجود عندها من سنه 79
لان الدول بتتعلم وهم برضو وهم بشر وهم
طيارات مختلفه والتيارات المختلفه دي
عندها قناعات مختلفه وعندها مصالح مختلفه
هم بيقسموهم معتدلين وصقور بس حتى داخل
المعتدلين والصقور دول فيهم اجنحه يعني
انا اشك يعني انه المساله مشروع ايدولوجي
مفتوح الى الابد هم
عانوا كثير يعني حرب العراقيه الايرانيه
دي كلفتهم الكثير جدا العقوبات كلفتهم
الكثير جدا الخلافات مع دول الخليج كلفتهم
الكثير جدا
اكيد عندهم شعب عاوز ياكل عاوز يشرب اكيد
الحكومه خايفه من انتفاضه الشعب اكيد امور
كتيره وبالتالي لازم يكون في نوع من
البريجماتيه اذا وجدوا ان العائد ممكن
يعني نتوقف مثلا تماما عنه كده في 2018
قالوا نوقف مثلا ونسمح للمجتمع الدولي كله
يشرف على برنامجنا النووي بس ارفعوا
العقوبات مثلا لما امريكا خرجت اوكي احنا
ممكن نرجع تاني بس عاوزين مقابل واحد
اثنين وتلاته هم يريدون رفعا للعقوبات
التي يعني ارهقتهم كثيرا
ويعني فكره ان هم بقى مش عارف الكلام
الشائع ان انا عاوز انشر التشيع واسقط
الانظمه اظن ان هذا امر اظن هذا امر
تجاوزه الزمن بالنسبه للايرانيين
وبعدين على فكره يعني على زي ما كان بيقول
عمرو موسى هو كان بيتكلم على مصر بس
الكلام هنا مش على مصر كان بيقول لا ولا
لو العالم غابه فمصر ليست قطه لو العالم
غابه ما الخليجين ليسوا قطعه برضه اثبتوا
ان هم قادرين انه يقدروا يعني
يصدروا متاعب للايران وطبعا بالاضافه الى
الولايات المتحده والغرب واسرائيل
لا ده تقريبا هو حاجه مشكله النهارده في
البرنامج انه يبدو انه اليوتيوب هو اللي
قاصدني بقى لان كتير هو اللي بيكرر
الاسئله انت اللي بتكرر الاسئله عمرو
ده ماندو من البيت
ماما هو اللي طيب كل سؤال بيتكرر كتير
ماشي الحال
عمل ايه يا حياه السلام عليكم وعليكم
السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته
اخونا كاتب اسم صعب عليا بس اوله قار يعني
اسامه ثروت هو كاتب اسمه ثروت كثر خيرك
اريد ان اعرف راي حضرتك في كلاوس
ذكي سؤال هي مارس اجبناه طيب
ما تعليقك على التطورات في السودان اجمناه
طيب
فهد عوض بيقول فهد العامري والله يكثر
خيرك ان انت كتبت الاسم بوضوح كده لما
تكتبوا الاسامي بالعربي بشعر بالارتياح
لانه كمان احيانا الاسامي بالانجليزي لو
انا نطتها زي ما هي ممكن
تدي قسمه مسيء يعني بيبقى مش متاكد
فبتجنبه فادي العامري بيقول نريد حلقه عن
الاقتصاد السعودي والله تستحق
السعوديه تستحق اقتص حلقه الاردن اقتصادها
عاوز حلقه
حاضر
بس حاضر يعني ليس في الوقت القريب لانه
على جدول الاعمال موضوعات كثيره وان شاء
الله هيكون في حلقه على الاقتصاد السعودي
والاقتصاد الاردني
رشيد اليس من العدل والانصاف القول ان ثمه
تطرف علماني في مقابل تطرف ديني في الشرق
الاوسط العداء والاردوغان نموذجا طبعا في
تطرف علماني اه طبعا يعني انت النهارده ما
هو اللي عمله ما هو احنا
ما هو التطرف العلماني ده هو اللي خلى فيه
ارضيه يتمدد فيها اربكان وتمدد فيها
اردوغان بلد مسلم تقريبا الاغلبيه في
مسلمه لما يجي مصطفى كمال اتاتورك او لما
يجي رضا بهلوي اللي هو ابو الشاه اللي تمت
الاطاحه به وبالغه جدا جدا في فرد في
مصادره الدين والحريات الدينيه وملاحقه
المحجبات وملاحقه اللغه العربيه وملاحقه
القران وملاحقه المتدينين دي مش علمانيه
يعني انا نازرع شيطاني وصهيونيه ومؤامره
الى اخره اوكي استخدموا الكلمه اللي انت
عاوزينها بس انا بقول انه العلمانيه اللي
عملها مصطفى كمال اتاتورك او رضا بهلوي
انا بعتبرها مش علمانيه بعتبره نوع من
التطرف العنيف جدا جدا جدا اللي في غير
محله انا عندي شعب مسلم عندي شعب بوزي
عندي شعب مسيحي المفروض ان انا لا الاحقه
لا اضطهدوا لانه عاوز يعبد الله وفقا
لدينه لكن العلمانيه تقول لي ايه انا اسمح
لك ان انت تعبد الله بل اشجعك روح لمساجدك
روح لكنائزك روح لمعبدك وانا احميك انا بس
اخد منك موقف لو انت مصر ان قناعاتك ديت
يجب ان تكون على حساب الاخرين احنا بنشوف
في بلادنا وده من السر مثلا يجي مش في
بلادنا وبلاد اخرى يجي التطرف انا مسلم طب
وانا قدامي
او في قريتي او في مدينتي ناس عاوزين
يقصدوا كنائسهم
انا ليه انا اروح احرق كناسهم لان انا
معتقد انه
مش عارف راح يحول الارض فضائل الى كنيسه
طب انت زعلان لي يعني حد بيصلي في ارض
فضاء ولا لا يعني انت ايه مشكلتك في
الحياه يعني مشكلتك ان في واحد عاوز يتقرب
الى الله على طريقه مختلفه ده اللي يزعجك
انت اللي يزعجك
ان حد يؤذيك في دينك اذا حد يزعجك انه حد
يمنعك من الصلاه واذا يمنعك يسيء الى دينك
بس لما اترك الجامعات تقرب الى الله ويعبد
الله وبالتالي انا اقيدك اذا كانت
التطرف في العلمانيه خطر شديد بل وجهل
غير مرغوب فيه يعني
على فكره رضا بهلوي كانت عنده مشكله
تقريبا تعاصر مع اردوغان مش اسف
مع مصطفى كمال اتاتورك الاثنين كان عندهم
افكار متطرفه جدا في ازاحه الدين عن
الساحه
الايرانيه او فكان في رد فعل بظهور الثوره
الاسلاميه في ايران وفي رد فعل بظهور بقى
الاحزاب بس كان الوضع في تركيا دايما الطف
واقل عنفا من ايران بظهور الاحزاب
الاسلاميه في تركيا
وبعدين ما فيش مشكله في انه ما حدش عنده
مشكله لان الرئيس اردوغان يكون اسلامي هو
الراجل مش متطرف ولا حزبه متهم بالتطرف
خالص احنا بنتكلم على سياسته الخارجيه بس
اللي هي ما حدش قال بالعكس ده كان انا في
2011 و 2010 و 2012 كتبت كتير على النموذج
الاردوغاني هل ممكن يبقى عندنا اردوغان في
اوجه التوراه كلنا كنا فرحانين جدا
باردوغان
بنموذجه باعتباره اثبت انه دوله اسلاميه
حزب اسلامي ما عندوش تناقضات عنيفه مع
الغرب من الصدام كان كلنا بنشد بيه
المشكله كلها جت لما بقت اردوغان تحول الى
سياسه عنيفه جدا
وبالتالي كانت مساله عليها علامات استفهام
بتصرفاته في ليبيا وفي مصر وفي سوريا وفي
دول الخليج وفي
[موسيقى]
ارمينيا في اماكن كثيره والناس اللي قالوا
لي ان الكلام ده كان كلام فارغ وان انت
كنت يعني مخطئ في حق اردوغان عندي حلقات
كثيره يقولوا لي الخطا كان فين لما
اردوغان دلوقتي تراجع عن كل هذا الكلام
يعني
ليه ما انا
طيب بلاش
ده في اسئله ما شاء الله عدد كبير
اه
انا بحاول ارجع لاخر سؤال يا شباب
ما شاء الله ده عدد
طيب
انا مش عارف ارجع للسؤال سامحوني لكن
طيب احاول تاني انا بحاول ارجع لنفس
السؤال لان في ناس بتزعل بتقول لي انت
بتعدي السؤال والله ما عديت ولا سؤال بس
احيانا الاسئله بتجري قدامي طيب
طيب انا كده رجعت للاول اصلا لكن معلش
هنرجع نتجاوز الاسئله اللي احنا عديناها
نصيحه لك
ما عمرك تعمل لايف وقت مباريات دوري
الابطال والله يا اخونا اولا انت حاضر اهو
فمعرفش انت بتتفرج معنا شويه وتتفرج على
ريال مدريد وسيتي شويه
الشباب قالوا لي الكلام ده بس انا كنت
نوهت ومن تجاربي لما انت بتعمل اعلانين
على نفس الحاجه بيحصل عمليه ارتباك الناس
هتستنى الساعه تمانيه او ناس الساعه تسعه
فانا قلت يعني اللي مش هيلحق وحريص هي
الحلقه بعد كده بتبقى مدعمه مفتوحه للناس
بس انا وجهت نظرك سليمه يعني بس انا شايف
ما شاء الله يعني انه الناس موجوده يعني
مش كده انا عارف انه كله هيتفرج الامر
نفسه يتفرج على سيتي وريال مدريد ولكن
روسيا شريكه لاوروبا بالطاقه ده
الواتساب انا مش عارف اقرا الاسم يعني
منتقبات الواتساب اظن روسيا شريكه لاوروبا
بالطاقه والغناء فلماذا اقدمت على
ومعاداتها بعرض النيتو لادخال اوكرانيا
فيه
انا مش عارف مين مين يعني اوروبا
روسيا كانت تتصرف على هذا النحو سواء بقى
ده يعني جاء على حساب علاقات باوروبا
بامريكا الى اخره لو انت تقصد ان اوروبا
ليه ما تعاطفتش مع المطالب الاوروبيه انا
اعتقد ان اوروبا لا حول لها ولا قوه وانه
هي نتيجه الضغوط الامريكيه
والضغوط البريطانيه لان بريطانيا يعني مش
من الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى لما كانت من
الاتحاد كانت دايما لها سياسات قريبه من
الولايات المتحده
يعني ورطوا الاوروبيين اللي منقسمين على
انفسهم لان اوروبا دي كتير وطبعا دول
البلطيق مثلا عندها كراهيه للروس فكانت
متعاطفه مع وجهه النظر الامريكيه هتلاقي
بولندا عندها مشاكل تاريخيه مع امريكا فقط
مع الولايات المتحده الدول اللي كانت
متفهمه
للمطالب الروسيه ودول كبيره زي المانيا
وفرنسا لم تستطع مقاومه الضغط الامريكي
عليهم
انهيار البترو دولار قريب كما يقول بعض
الاقتصاديين هل البترو دولار ده اخونا عمر
عباس كما يقول بعض الاقتصاديين والسياسيين
وماذا قد تكون اثر ذلك على المواطن المصري
بشكل عام وعلى الدوله المصريه بشكل خاص في
ظل الاتفاقات الاسريه والسياسيه ده موضوع
اكبر من مصر كتير بقى ده ممكن العالم كله
انت بتقول البترو دولار ده يعني ايه
المقصود بالدولار انه الدول المنتجه
للبترول وتحديدا دول الخليج بقياده
السعوديه لانه السعوديه كانت اكبر دوله
خارجيه وهي التي وقعت هذا الاتفاق مع
الامريكان في سنه 74 ان هي لا تبيع
بترولها الا بالدولار ثم الفائض عن حاجتها
من بيع البترول يستثمر في تمويل العجز
الامريكي يعني التسلف به الحكومه
الامريكيه في مقابل توفير الدفاع للدول
الخليج او للسعوديه وفي مقابل اسعار
التفضيليه لها في السندات الامريكيه لو
الوضع ده واضح يبقى جميل لو مش واضح
اكتبوا لي ونخصص له حلقه
ما هو البترول الامريكي ما هو البترو
دولار
اذا غيرت دول الخليج وباعت الدولار وبعت
البترول بغير الدولار هتبقى خطوه دراميه
جدا هتاثر على سياده الدولار انا مش متخيل
ان امريكا تسمح بكده لان امريكا المساله
دي بالنسبه لها خط احمر مش متاكد ان مصالح
الخليجيين وصلت الى هذا الخصام مع امريكا
الى هذا الحد فالتدعيات هتكون على العالم
كلهم مصر دوله من دول العالم لكن التاثير
الحقيقه هيكون على
عدد كبير من الدول
مصر مش طرف اساسي في الموضوع ولكن دول
الخليج طرف اساسي في الموضوع
برايك كيف توافق الدول العربيه على عوده
سوريا بشروط ولم نسمع اي مسؤول سوري صرح
بانهم وافق على هذه الشروط وخصوصا القرار
الامم بتغيير سياسي والله يعني انا يعني
المساله هم اتفقوا على المفاوضات
اكيد الخطاب السوري اللي الخطاب الداخلي
السوري هيتكلم على نجاح الحكومه السوريه
بصمودهم في ان تجبر الجميع للعوده اليها
راكعين خاضعين ومسلمين بقوتها ده اللي
لازم هتقوله وده طبيعي للدول بتستخدم خطاب
يعني لمغازله الناس وفي نفس الوقت المساله
الحقائق واحده لكن المسميات مختلفه يعني
هم هيتفاوضوا على امور كثيره السوريين
شاطرين في التفاوض هيحاولوا ياخدوا اكبر
قدر ممكن من الامتيازات والتنازلات اللي
هيقدموها ان سميت تنازل هيحاولوا يسوقوها
بطريقه جيده لمؤيديهم يعني
انما لازم يكون في شروط امال هم هيدوا
مساعدات لسوريا ليه امال هم هيحاولوا
يتوسطوا للغرب لرفع العقوبات ليه امال كل
الحاجات دي ما هو لازم يكون في شروط مش
معقوله يعني هم اصلا هو الراجل مش مش في
وضع ان هو يفرض عليهم يعني ما لا يريدونه
هم اللي في وضع ممكن يعني يضغطوا عليه اذا
كان ولابد حد يضغط على التاني لماذا لا
تقوم روسيا بغتيال زيلينسكي الاجابه يا
اخونا جاءت على لسان رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
السابق الناس اسمه دلوقتي اللي هو
اللي هو اللي كان قبل لابيد اللي قعد شهور
قليله
ده قال انه هو اخذ تعهد راح يمارس بعد
اندلاع الحرب في 22 بشهر واحد واخذ تعهد
من بوتين بالا يقتل زيلينسكي واتصل
بسيلينسكي وابلغه وبوتين قال له انا ما
عنديش يعني ليس من اهدافي ان اقتله
لانه انا مخططي في يعني
في
اوكرانيا ملوش علاقه بتصفيه القيادات اللي
موجوده السياسيه هو اعطى تعهد للغرب
وبالمناسبه هذا التعاقد واضح انه كمان
للسياسيين اللي بيقتوا لزياره
لانه مكانه معروف والمطار معروف وتقدر
الصواريخ الروسيه تطالب يعني
على فكره على عكس الناس ما بتعتقد يعني
الكثير من القنوات الداخليه بتتكشف لنا في
كل الصراعم بتضع قواعد كثيره للحرب ما هو
لسه كنا بنتكلم في عن الشان الفلسطيني
واللبناني هو ليه اسرائيل ما بتسعاش مثلا
الاغتيال مثلا
معهم
دايما بتكون الحروب لها يعني قواعد
بتنظمها مش بالشكل المفتوح ده انا بدخل في
حرب مع دوله فبدمرها بالكامل يعني علشان
يظل في فرصه للتفاوض علشان يكون التصعيد
برده في حدود
لا تتجاوزوا وبالتالي يسهل التفاوض مع
الطرف الاخر هو في الاخر مش هيحتل
اوكرانيا خالص هو محتاج حكومه تمثل
اوكرانيا يتفاوض معاها على اكبر قدر ممكن
من التناسلات اذا
اغتالزنسكي واذا اغتال القيادات يتفاهم مع
مين يعني
لو سمحت هل سيؤثر اقرا الكونجرس قانون
محاربه التطبيع مع سوريا على جهود الدوله
العربيه نعم سوف يؤثر اذا ظل في مكانه لكن
واضح ان الاداره الامريكيه زي ملفات كتيره
اللي بتقول اه ولا بتقول لا فهذا شجع
الدول العربيه وفي ناس بتوحي بانه
الامريكان مش رافضين لان في مسؤوله
امريكيه في وزاره الخزانه نصيحتي ليكم
احصلوا من بشار الاسد على اكبر قدر ممكن
من المكاسب في مقابل التطبيع معهم يعني
معنى ذلك ان هم لن يطبقوا عليهم قانون
قيصر والعقوبات فالموقف الامريكي مش واضح
قوي لكن واضح ان هو ليس بلغي التشدد في
مساله التطبيع مع بشار الاسد في هذه
المرحله
تحليل حضرتك العلاقه مصري بدول الخليج وهل
يوجد فعلا خلافات تستدعي الخليج لدعم
لدعم رئيس في المستقبل القريب غير الرئيس
الحالي
لا ما اعرفش انه في خلافات الى حد ان هم
يسعوا لدعم رئيسه ما اعرفش انه في حد في
الصوره في الوقت الحالي بينافس الرئيس
المصري تقصد في الانتخابات في 2024 لا
اعتقد انه في معلومه تتعلق بوجود منافس
وان هذا المنافس يحظى مثلا بدعم دول
الخليج وبالمناسبه دول الخليج ليسوا على
قلب رجل واحد يعني مين دول الخليج
سلطنه عمان لها سياسه مستقله خالص قطر
سياسه مستقله خالص الكويت لها سياسه
مستقله تماما
الامارات
والسعوديه بيتوافقوا احيانا الامارات
والسعوديه والبحرين
بيتوافقوا احيانا ويختلفوا احيانا كثيرا
واكبر خلاف مثلا كان على زي مثلا الموقف
من بشار الاسد من 2018 البحرين والامارات
ذهبوا السعوديه تلكات او رفضت
فاحنا مش بنتكلم على كتله واحده
هي لاعب هي اللاعب الاقوى ولكنها
على حسب المنطقه يعني يعني مثلا فيما
يتعلق
باسيا وافريقيا هي ليست اللاعب الاقوى في
اوروبا هي اللاعب الاقوى على حسب المنطقه
لكن اقدر اقول لك بدل كلمه بين وبالتالي
يعني هي اقوى لاعب نعم لكنها لم تعد اللعب
الذي يحتكر اوراق
كل القضايا يعني
محمد لماذا تركيا واسرائيل وايران لديهم
صناعات عسكريه متطوره والدول العربيه ليس
لديها ذلك لانهم عندهم علم وتعليم اكثر
تطورا بكثير جدا جدا جدا مش معقوله في دول
عربيه
نسبه الاميه فيها 17 و18 و20 بالاميه
الرسميه هم بيحسبوا الناس اللي دخلوا
المدرسه في ناس دخلت المدرسه ويعني قطعت
سنوات وما بتعرفش تقرا وتكتب يعني حتى
الاميه اللي هي القرايه والكتابه فده ما
تتوقعش ان هم يطلعوا مثلا الاف العلماء
كما هو الوضع في تركيا كما هو الوضع في
ايران كما هو الوضع في اسرائيل دول ظروفهم
تعليم اقوى وبالتالي
مستوياتهم التصنيعيه اعلى مننا
بلاش البلاش والله يسامحك اللي سنه يسال
ما فهمتش السؤال يا فيصل
ليه مصر ودول العالم مش بتتعامل بالعملات
المحليه مع بعض الدول في الاستيراد
والتصدير انا عاوز اريحك في مساله التعامل
بالعمله البحريه انت عشان تتعامل معاملتك
المحليه لازم يكون عندك اللي تبيعه للناس
انا هدي زي مثلا مصر هتبيع
تتعامل بالجنيه المصري زي مع روسيا لازم
يكون روسيا عاوزه كتير سلع كتيره وخدمات
كثيره من مصر عشان تحتفظ بالجنيه فتستخدمه
لكن انا لو خدت منك الجنيه بتاعك وانا ما
عنديش حاجه اشتريها ما عندكش حاجه من انت
ما عندكش حاجه تبيعها لي انا هعمل ايه
بالجنيه بتاعك انت بتستفيد مثلا بدات
الدول تتعامل باليوان الصيني لانه هم
عندهم سلع كثيره ممكن يشتروها من الصين او
بتتعامل بالدولار الامريكي لانه مقبول في
امريكا ومقبول في دول كثيره غير امريكا
ممكن تستخدم الدولار لكن انت الجنيه بتاعك
ما عندكش سلع كثيره سواء سلع او خدمات انت
بتعرضها للعالم وعملتك طبعا مش مقبوله لدى
دول اخرى الحل الاساسي مش في انك انت تدور
على العرض او التفاصيل حل الاساسي لمصر
والدول الاخرى ان هي تقوي اقتصادها بان
يكون عندها
سلع وخدمات كثيره يحتاجها العالم
لدي سؤال لماذا كل هذا الهجوم والتصعيد
على سميح سوارس بسبب تصريحاته عن نقل
استثماراتي الى السعوديه محمد
محمد انا مش عارف اقرا الاسم التاني
بنطرجم انا يعني انا ما اعرفش مين هاجم
انا عارف ان في هجوم بس انا ما تابعتش
الفئات اللي هجمته ولكن طبعا الحكم لم تكن
سعيده بهذا لانه لما يجي مستثمر كبير يعبر
عن هذه يعبر عن اراءه بهذا الموضوع طبعا
محبط جدا جدا لهم
وبيحرجهم داخليا قبل ما بيحرجهم خارجيا
وفي بعض الناس عن طبعا اقول ايه يعني
بتفكر بمشاعرها شويه حاسس ان هو يعني
يعني عبر بوضوح عما هو مسكوت عنه لكن انا
اعتقد ان الراجل ما قالش حاجه غريبه
الراجل بيقول انا هستثمر ازاي وانا مش
عارف اسعر الجنيه يعني انا يعني الدولار
بتاعي ده يبقى بكام يعني اعمل جلسات جدوى
علي على دولار باربعين ولا بواحد وتلاتين
ولا بتسعه وتلاتين بايه يعني دي بدايه ده
بالعكس ده هو كلام الراجل انا بشوفه انه
كان خفيف جدا لان لما المذيعه سالته عن
مزاحمه الدوله للقطاع الخاص قال دي مشكله
ثانويه وهي دي المشكله الشائكه اللي ناس
بتتخوف في الكلام فيها او بتتحرك في
الكلام فيها انما هو اتكلم على مشكله كل
الناس بيتكلموا عليها والحكومه لا تنكرها
يعني انا مش شايف ان الهجوم
الا هذا السبب ان الحكومه كانت تتمنى ان
مستثمر كبير زي سميح ما يتكلمش بهذا الشكل
يعني
بناء منيف
مناف اسف سؤال الا تمتلك مصر فائض من
القوه العسكريه يسمح لها
بالتدخل في كل من ليبيا والسودان ولماذا
تبقى مصر متفرجه ولا تتدخل عسكريا كما هو
حال تركيا وايران رغم التهديد المباشره
للمصالح المصريه شوفوا
لدي فائد قوه لديها فائده قوه لكن تعمل
ايه بيفائده القوه انت ضربت مثل بايران
وضربت مثل بتركيا هي تركيا استفادت كثيرا
يعني بتدخلها العسكري في كل هذه الجبهات
التدخل العسكري افادها مره واضرها بشده في
مرات اخرى وبالتالي انت هتتدخل عسكريه
تعمل ايه في ليبيا مثلا التدخل العسكري ان
انت تنضم مثلا لفريق فتقتل باقي الليبيين
ما هي القصه ديت هيكون لها اولا تورتك في
صراع مفتوح لانه صراع ليبيين في ليبيين
هيورثك في مشاكل سنوات طويله وسوف تظل
هناك غصه بين الليبيين
لانه ابنائهم قتل على ايدي الجيش المصري
نفس القصه بالنسبه للسودانيين انت بيكون
عندك انحيازات ممكن تدعم بحساب النبي
بيفضل مساله التدخل العسكري ديت عليها
سؤالين سؤال الاول ما جدواه هيحقق لي ايه
السؤال الثاني تكلفته على المدى البعيده
بالنسبه للشعوب انت مرتبط بها ارتباط وثيق
مع وافر الاحترام لتركيا علاقتها في ليبيا
مش هي علاقه مصر بليبيا
معافر الاحترام علاقه ايران
للشعب السوداني مش هي علاقه مصر
بالسودانيين دي الدول
تشارك مصر في حدود
عائلات
ومواطنين بالملايين من اليمين والسودانيين
موجوده وبالتالي العلاقه ابديه فلازم تبقى
المساله محسوبه يعني ايه ادخل ادخل اعمل
ايه وهل دخولي ده لما كان الاول تقول هي
ما دخلتش في اثيوبيا ليه بالقوه العسكريه
طب ما عندها فائض قوه تقدر تضرب السد
وتقدر لكن المساله بتتحسب
تاثير هذا القرار تداعياته على اثيوبيا
على علاقته باثيوبيا على المدى البعيد اذا
ضربت السد هيكون رد الفعل الاثيوبي ايه رد
فعل الدول الافريقيه ايه رد الدول الكبرى
اللي بتسندها ايه او الدول الاقليميه اللي
بتساندها وهكذا
لو افترضنا توقف العالم ده اخونا
ماذا لو لو
افترضنا توقف العالم عن استعمال المحروقات
نهائيا متى تتوقع من تتوقع ستكون اقوى
ثلاث بلدان عربيه اقتصاديا ده سؤال بقى
يعني عاوز كده ايه موديلز رياضيه افتراضيه
ممكن هم يكونوا اشطر مني فيه لكن
ده بيت الحكمه بيقول ما هو اثر ازمه سقف
الدين الامريكي على سعر الذهب
هو العلاقه هتبقى لو انه ازمه استمرت
وفقدت للناس الثقه في الدولار هيذهبوا الى
بدائل فمن ضمن البدائل الدهب بس انا حاسس
انه يكون بدري شويه لان الازمه ديت
المستثمرين يعتدوها ومتوقعين الحل في
تقديري يعني انا طبعا مش خبير في اسعار
الذهب لكن انا بقول ده ده التفسير اللي هو
ممكن يمشي ده اللي ممكن يمشي
شتاء صرمدي
برايك كيف توافق الدول العربيه
ده احنا اجبناه
كنت قد قلت سابقا ده اخونا صلاح او صالح
حامد كنت قد قلت سابقا ان الشعوب التي
تحكمها الدوله الوحش يعني محظوظه بالنسبه
للدول المنهاره لكن اليست الدول المنهاره
نفسها كانت دوله وحش مثل سوريا والعراق
والله سؤال جميل جدا صحيح ما هو ايوه انت
عندك حق هو هو بيقول سؤال يعني سؤال صالح
عميق شويه في حلقه اتكلمنا فيها عن الدول
العربيه
يعني
تكره الديمقراطيه ام انها غير مستعده لها
وبعدين نفس الكتاب تاني انا خدت هذا
المقتطف وعرضته في حدود عشر دقايق
عن نظريه
توماس هوبس اللي هو مشهور بين الفلاسفه
بانه هو الراجل اللي هو فيلسوف الاستبداد
هو ما كانش عاوز يدعم الاستبداد ولا حاجه
يعني انتم طبعا لو شفتوا الحلقتين
هتعرفوا صالح قصده ايه فممكن ترجعوا لهم
لكن هي باختصار كده هو الراجل كان بيقول
ايه
1650 معي عمرو ولا نمت طيب
انا هسالك في نهايه الحلقه
ماندو كنت بساله وكان هنشوف شوف مين اللي
هيطلع الاول فكان
فكرته ببساطه يعني انه كان في حاله انفلات
وحروب اهليه في بريطانيا او في انجلترا
وقتها يعني
فكان بيقول انه الحل انه يجي صابرين ملك
يكون عنده سلطات مطلقه لانه في وجود
الفوضى ديت مش هينفع حكايه انه الاراء
المتعدده وانه يبقى في مراكز قوه كتيره
لازم واحد يجي يوقف
شلالات الدم ديت في ندي له صلاحات مطلقه
في مقابل انه يحفظ لنا ارباحنا ودمائنا
ظروف القصه دي
لكن المساله دي تطورت هو بقى صالح بيقول
ايه ما هو نتيجه انه الراجل
السفرين ده او الملك ده ديكتاتوري جدا
فبيكون النتيجه انه زي ما حصل مثلا في
نظام صدام حسين او غيره يعني النتيجه ان
الشعوب بتثور عليه فبتحصل الفوضى كلامك
صحيح ده صحيح جدا بس انا بقول ايه
الواقع الحل الافضل يا اخونا صالح
انه ليكون عندنا دوله وحش ولا تكون عندنا
دوله رخوه منهاره الافضل يكون عندنا دوله
رشيده ودي يعني مش حلم ولا حاجه الرئيس
فيها بياتي يستند في شرعته الى قبول الناس
ولما استند الى قبول الناس يبقى القصه انه
عنده ممكن صلاحيات طب ما هو ارتفاع عنده
صلاحيات كثيره والغرب بيعتبروا ديكتاتور
انما ده مبالغه من الغرب ايوه عندهم
مقارنه بمستشار الالماني او المستشاره
المستشار الالماني او الرئيس الفرنسي عنده
صلاحيات شبه مطلقه بس ده بالمعايير
الغربيه المتطوره جدا احنا ما وصلناش
للمعايير دي هم وصلوا لها بعد 300 سنه
فممكن يبقى عندك صلاحيات اكثر من المعتاد
في الديمقرايات الديمقراطيات المتطوره جدا
انما ليست صلاحيات مطلقه تسمح لك بانك انت
يكون عندك
تحكم في كل مفاصل الدوله وكاسم على صدور
الناس وما فيش انتخابات وما فيش فرصه
للتعبير عن الاراء النتيجه انه يحصل عمليه
انفجار يحصل انفجار مش بالضروره بس لان
الناس بتحب الحريه لانه
الديكتاتوريات اللي هي غاشمه جدا ما
بتقدرش تعمل حلول خلاقه الحلول الخلاقه
ديت معناها ان انا بطرق حتى لو عندك شركه
ان اراء مختلفه بتسمع اراء الناس وبتاخد
افضلها انتخابات طبيعي للافكار لكن لما
انت بتكون متسلط جدا وبعد فتره بتحيط نفسك
بمجموعه وان اللي بيعلي صوته
بيعاقب وبيقصى فالناس كلها بتلزم الصمت
والاصوات الوحيده المسموعه هي اصوات
المنافقين وارازل الناس يعني لازم الدوله
بتضعف فكلامك صحيح وكلام اللي انا قلته
للتوضيح بقول ان احنا قدام واقع سيء
الواقع السيء والماساوي ده ان احنا قدامك
اما حكومات الحكومه فيها اقوى مما ينبغي
على حساب الشعب او
ان ما فيش حكومه اصلا واذا كان ولابد من
الخيار اكيد اكيد هختار حكومه متسلطه على
ان اختار دوله لا يوجد فيها اي سلطه ان
انا لا امن على نفسي ولا على اولادي ولا
على بيتي ولا على ممتلكاتي ولا على
هكذا يعني هذا ما اقصده يعني
اخونا السيد بيقول ليه مصر والدول العالم
مش بتتعامل بالعملات اكابنا كيف حكمت
الدوله الامويه مئات السنوات الغرب والشرق
وهي تطبق الشريعه الاسلاميه الادهم
لا املك اجابه يعني انا مش فاهم هدف سؤالك
يعني انا ما اعرفش ايه المقصود وانا لست
مؤرخا يعني
انما لو وضحت لي الهدف من السؤال اللي انا
اظنه دلوقتي بحاول افتكر انت بتتكلم على
يعني انا مش عارف يعني لو وضحت لي السؤال
شويه لان انا اظن ان احنا طرحنا شيء مثل
هذا يعني فلو وضحت لي سؤالك افضل تبقى
الاجابه محدده بدل ما
نسبح في الفضاء الخارجي يعني
برايك كيف توافق الدول العربيه على العوده
اجابنا كيف ترى انت والمحللون المصريون
والوضع العراقي وهي الرئيس الوزراء محمد
السوداني سينجح في وضع العراق على السكه
حسب قراءتك
ومسموعك تحياتنا استاذنا ده اخونا حمزه
اكيد من العراق
انا ما اعرفش باقي المحللين بيقولوا ايه
ومش عارف قدره رئيس الوزراء محمد السوداني
انه ينجح في انه يخرج به العراق من الازمه
انا عارف انه السوداني وقبله الكاظمي
وبعدهم اي رئيس وزراء مع عوافر الاحترام
رئيس الحكومه العراقي هو ما عندوش قاعده
تمكنه هو كان عنده كرسي او اتنين داخل
البرلمان وبالتالي هو ما لوش قاعده كبيره
يعني تمكنه من ان هو ياخد قرارات جريئه
انما يمكن ان يكون شخصيه متوافق عليها في
الداخل معنى كده ان نجاحهم بتوافق القوى
الكتيره في السودان في العراق
والقوه ديت لن تهدا من تلقاء نفسها لان هي
مجيره
هي
عندها حلفاء في الخارج يعني من الاخر
امريكا
ايران دول الخليج تركيا لازم الدول دي
تكون متوافه يتعلق باليمن مفيش امل غير
انه لما يتوافقوا السعوديه وايران وبمجرد
ما توافقه بدات في بوادر اذا الوفاق استمر
اكيد مشكله اليمن هتبقى اقل حده
مشكور لجهودك استاذ سيد
احب اعرف اعرف هل من الممكن ان تعود
امريكا للاهتمام بالشرق الاوسط هي عاده
للاهتمام بالشرق الاوسط ولكن العوده
للاهتمام بالشرق الاوسط الذي لم يخفت
يختلف عن انك تلعب دور
يعني هي مهتمه ومش عاوزه تسيب الشرق
الاوسط للصين ولا للروس ولا غيرهم ولا لاي
قوه اقليميه تركيه ايران بس في فرق زي ما
بيقولوا كده
القول المشهور المنسوب للسيد المسيح عليه
السلام النفس راغبه والجسد ضعيف هي راغبه
لكن مش قادره
وبالتالي هي مش قادره يعني
تحط بقى زي ما بيقولوا كده افنجرنيفر ان
انا احط ان انا اكون متدخل في كل الشؤون
عندها وجهه نظر في السودان بس مش قادر
تستثمر قوي في النزاع السوداني ده محتاج
دبلوماسيين ومحتاج اموال ومحتاج جهد لها
مصلحه في الوضع في ليبيا بس ما عندهاش
قدره ان هي تعمل مبعوث خاص وتبعت
فريق دبلوماسي وتكثف الاتصالات وترسل
بوارك حربيه في كل الصراع الصراعات كثيره
جدا حوالين العالم ورئيس مجلس اداره هذا
الكون اللي هو الولايات المتحده اصبح مسنا
المجهدا بيفضل ان هو
يخصص جهده للقضايا المهمه قوي
انا هستاذنكم كمان
عشر دقائق ونكتفي
يعني نقفل على عشره وخمسين
ما دقه خبر قصف روسي لمخزن اوكراني من
قنبله من القنبله القذره المخصبه لغايه
النهارده الصبح انا ما اعرفش معلومات
بالنسبه لحكايه القنبله القادره اللي انت
بتقول عليها
انا سمعت عن جسم غريب انا مش عارفه فانا
حتى
ظهر اليوم لان انا كنت مشغول في التسجيل
حلقات
في الاستوديو وبالتالي انا ما تابعتش
بالنسبه للدعاء اتفاق سوري ايراني بالتخلي
عن الملف اليمني لصالح سوريا انا لا
استطيع ان افهمه ماذا يمكن لماذا ممكن ان
يتوافقوا للتخلي عن اليمن لسوريا ماذا
يمكن لسوريا ان تفعله في اليمن فانا
اذا كان السؤال على هذا النحو فانا لم
اسمع به ولا استطيع ان افهمه
جابر بيقول هل الرؤيه العامه عن
الانتخابات التركيه انها تتصف بالنزاهه ام
هل تواجه مهاجمه لنظام الانتخابات على
غرار الولايات المتحده
يعني هي انتخابات صحيحه ولكنها انتخابات
معيبه بمعايير
الدول الاوروبيه اللي هي عندها ديمقراطيه
مستقله يعني مثلا
طبعا ما فيش انتخابات بتاخده من تجاوز بس
مثلا هم بياخذوا على الانتخابات التركيه
ان السلطه القائمه
بتفعل ما لا تستطيع السلطه القائمه في
الدول الديمقراطيه يعني مثلا لما الرئيس
التركي يعمل زياده لموظفه دوله 45% قبل
الانتخابات باربع ايام لما يعطي غازا شبه
مجاني او مجاني للبيوت لما هو
يستغل الاعلام مره انا مش متاكد بس دي
يعني مراسل او محرك بيقول ان التليفزيون
في اسبوع واحد سبق الانتخابات اعطى 31
ساعه تغطيه
للرئيس التركي فيما اعطى 31 دقيقه انا ليه
متشكك في الرقم لان 31 مش بالضروره يعني
31 ساعه انما يقصد وده صحيح عدد ساعات
كبيره جدا لرئيس التركي والتليفزيون لما
تساله طب ما انا بغطي اخبار الرئيس التركي
يعني عنده اخبار كثيره
يعني فده بيعتبروه من عدم النزاهه يعني
انما محدش هيقول عندما يفوز اردوغان اذا
فاز ان الانتخابات دي مزوره ولكن لا لا
تتصف بالنزاهه المطلقه يعني
استاذ سيد جبيل هل التطبيع السعودي مع
ايران والاسد هي خطوه لتامين التطبيع
السعودي مع اسرائيل من رده فعل ايران
وحليفتها اي ان مقابل ما قدمته السعوديه
لايران وسوريا ستتغاضى ايران عن التطبيع
السعودي
الاسرائيلي
لاخونا بوتين بيقول كده
انما انا يعني انا يعني يعني
ما تقدرش تصيغ المساله على هذا النحو
السعوديه عندها مصالح كبيره جدا في
التطبيع مع الايرانيين ومع السوريين بقطع
النظر عن مسار التطبيع مع اسرائيل الذي لا
يبدو قريبا
لاحظ ان التطبيع الرسمي مكلف للسعوديين
بالنظر الى انه ما تريده او ممكن ان تاخذه
من اسرائيل يمكن ان تحصل عليها بدون تطبيع
اذا كانت عاوزه سلاح ما هي ممكن تحصل على
سلاح وممكن ما تحصلش على السلاح
الاسرائيلي كله على بعضه وتعتمد على دول
اخرى يعني فانا يعني لا اتفق مع وجهه
النظر دي اللي بيقيدها لبعض واللي بيقولها
البعض
انما ممكن تستغل
طبعها مع ايران
يعني ممكن تستفيد من المصارين من المصارين
ان هي تتبع مع ايران معناها انه
ايران قد لا تشعر
بخطر شديد اذا ذهبت السعوديه لاسرائيل
وتستغل كمان تطبيقها مع ايران في الضغط
على اسرائيل في ان هي تحصل منها على
تنازلات كبيره في مقابل التطبيع معها هذه
سنوات بصراحه يعني السنوات المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
متكرره
اسئله متكرره طيب سامي نصر استاذ سيد جبيل
ارجو ان تبث حلقه عن الذكاء الاصطناعي
سامي انا احنا عملنا حلقتين مع الدكتور
احمد بهاء الدين هل تقصد حلقات اخرى اذا
كنت تقصد كده بكل سرور لان احنا حتى
ذكرتني بموعد يعني
او اصدقاء اخرين يعني الدكتور احمد بهاء
واصدقاء اخرين من المتخصصين في الذكاء
الصناعي
هل بضعف الامبراطوريه الامريكيه
هل يضعف الامبراطوريه الامريكيه لسداد
دينهم هل ترى حضرتك هذا مؤشر وفولها يعني
انا
ده فتيمه اه طبعا يا استاذه فتيمه بديهي
انه الامبراطوريات اللي بتسرف في
الاستدانه بتكون واحده من علامات افولها
وضياعها ده في نظريه بتقول الامبراطوريه
الرومانيه كان واحده من اهم اسباب
الاسراف في طباعه النقد
نتيجه ضعف مواردها من الذهب يعني طبعا ما
في شك في هذا ما في شك في هذا
وعلى فكره في حلقه بعنوان هل نشهد الايام
الاخيره للامبراطوريه الامريكيه استاذنكم
ان تعودوا في ليها وفيها كلام عن هذا
المؤشر احنا فضل لنا اربع دقايق
ما هي توقعاتك للاوضاع في اليمن ومطالب
الجنوب وحضرموت بالاستقلال وعمليه السلام
المرتقبه شوف يا صديقي ده احنا صديقنا هنا
نبدا
انا ما عنديش للاسف الشديد ما يدعوني
للتفاؤل فيما يتعلق باليمن لانه كل اللي
بيحصل دلوقتي من جانب السعوديه وايران
وكذا ان كل دوله عاوزه تحافظ على مصالحها
يعني اللي يعني السعوديه بصراحه يعني من
الاخر ان حدودها الجنوبيه تهدا
بتهدئه مع الحوثيين وحبذا لو سلام وما
يعني الايرانيين انه نفوذهم في اليمن
يترجم الى وسائل ضغط تحصل بموجبه على
التنازلات من الغرب ودول الخليج الى اخره
انما ما يعني اليمنيين بقى هو ان هم
يتصالحوا مع الحوثيين او يتصالحوا فيما
بينهم وتستقر الاوضاع في اليمن باتصال او
انفصال يعني شمال وجنوب او بانفصال الجنوب
امر بعيد المنال
ويحتاج الى سنوات ولا توجد مؤشرات على ان
البيئه الموجوده دلوقتي اول المنتظره يمكن
ان تؤدي الى
استقرار في اليمن
سؤال اخير
لاخونا سيدي اخذ الرايه من صديقه من الاخر
وكرر سؤاله ليه السؤال العملات المحليه ما
انا اجبت يا صديقنا وسؤال زي اللي نسكي
كذلك
انما ما زال في بعض المصادر التي لا
تحضرني فورا كتاب معينين في بعض الدوريات
والمصادر المحترمه بيتمتعوا بقدر معقول
جدا من الموضوعيه
قد يصعب عليك الوصول اليهم لان هم قليلين
في كل مكان انما الاجابه المختصره اذا كنت
مهتم جدا للحصول الى معلومات الموضوعيه
هتبذل مجهود كبير
اتقرا في مصادر متناقده هتضطر تستخدم
او يعني حسك في انك تعرف خلفيه كل واحد
وتاخذ منه تاخذ منه
واشياء وترفض اشياء اخرى يعني
في الدقيقه الاخيره
لماذا
لماذا جلس عسكر مصر مؤخرا مع البوليساريو
في الجزائر ولماذا لا تعترف مصر بالمغربيه
الصحراء انا معرفش يعني ايه جلس عسكر مصري
الحكومه المصريه جلسوا معاه
انا ما عنديش فكره ان في لقاء مؤخر بس
عارف ان موقف الحكومه المصريه هو موقف من
دول اخرى بيقولوا احنا موقفنا زي موقف
الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده وبيقولوا
ان هذه الارض تحتاج الى او هذا الخلاف بين
جبهه والمغرب مش واخدين موقف المغرب كاملا
يعني وبيقولوا انه عليكم ان انتم تتفاوضوا
مع بعض وتجروا الاستفتاء القديم ما يعني
ان موقفهم
المعلن لا يرضي المغرب كثيرا انما هم
ليسوا في حاله عداء احنا اصدقائي استاذنكم
نتوقف عند هذا القدر
انا عارف انه في عدد
كبير لسه من الاسئله
يعني معلش استاذنكم ان انتم تسامحوني احنا
مبدئيا هنجرب مقترحكم بانه اللقاء يكون
مره كل اسبوع
لمده شهر او يعني شهر ونصف كده اذا كان
هذا مفيدا سوف نستمر اذا وجدت ان هذا مزعج
وان ده مش محل يعني اهتمامكم هنعود مره
اخرى الى الهواء كل اسبوعين لكن انا
استجبت لرغبتكم من به اللقاء مره كل اسبوع
وبالتالي في فرصه لاصدقائنا اللي لم نستطع
الاجابه على اسئلتهم ان هي تروحوها في
الاسبوع المقبل ورجاء رجاء رجاء بلاش
تكرار السؤال عشرين وتلاتين مره هذا مجهد
جدا ليا وبيخليني اتجاوز اسئله لا استطيع
قراءتها اذا احيانا الله الاربعاء المقبل
اعتذر عن المباشر لظروف صفر قصير يعني
لحضور مؤتمر فان شاء الله اذا احيانا الله
نلتقي الاربع بعد القادم وسوف نواصل
اللقاء المباشر كل اربعاء لمده شهر ونصف
يبدا من الان على سبيل التجربه واذا نجحت
التجربه نستمر ان شاء الله اشكركم شكرا
جزيلا والقاكم على خير
الاربعاء بعد المقبل